The North Cold Atomic has
appeared.
Marble isn't it.
Yeah. Yeah.
I thought there was a chance to exchange words, but my head turned white. Calm down.
[Music]
Why do you often get annoyed suddenly at the last minute
?
You'll have to wear it
again. It's because you're going to wear it. It's like you were told to hold a meeting.
Your scam  I'd like to ask you a few questions about the act, but
wait a minute, is it my business story by fraud,
is there a person here who can prove that I have no psychic ability,
or the victim who can prove the fraud is damaged?  Nothing says yes Yes
Why do you say that to a self-proclaimed victim?
I'm not a criminal who can still be a self-proclaimed psychic champion while the truth is uncertain.
So the question is, do you have psychic powers?
No comment. Why don't you answer? It's a question that can only be solved by answering
.
I can't prove that you have no inspiration.
Do you intend to do it?
As far as I saw the live broadcast, it seems that ad lib is good,
but now I heard a scam, but no,
it's just a microphone test.